every year reporters and editors at
science choose 9 runners-up and one
breakthrough of the year they look for
the most significant scientific
discoveries developments and trends but
before we get to the breakthrough here
are the runners-up in a detector beneath
the South Pole a ghostly particle called
a neutrino left a telltale track
researchers traced it back to its likely
source a bright galaxy called a blaze
armed far away the findings suggest
Blazers may also be the source of
mysterious ultra high-energy cosmic rays
deep beneath the Greenland ice sheet
scientists have discovered a massive
crater it was created by the impact of a
mountain sized asteroid the impact is
relatively recent and hasn't yet been
firmly dated but the event may help
explain some puzzling climate changes
this ancient fossil is more than half a
billion years old but was it an animal
an intriguing find suggests it was
scientists discovered traces of
cholesterol a signature of animal life
associated with these fossils the feat
indicates the fossils which belonged to
a mysterious class called ediacara where
some of Earth's earliest animals
the first drug based on a gene silencing
reaction called RNA interference or RNAi
I won approval this year for use in the
United States and Europe researchers
discovered RNA I which blocks messenger
RNA twenty years ago and the drug which
targets a rare hereditary disease could
be the first of many tel recently sexual
harassment in science has been
underreported and largely ignored the
2018 brought signs of change several
institutions upheld allegations against
prominent scientists accused of sexual
harassment discrimination and bullying
and the u.s. National Academies of
science issued a report calling for
systemic changes to prevent such abuse
[Music]
this year saw increasing evidence that
cellular components condense into tiny
droplets a process called phase
separation the droplets can perform
critical functions researchers have
found they play an unexpected role in
the transcription of genes and they
identified a possible path to dissolving
solidified droplets at clogged the brain
and contribute to diseases such as
amyotrophic lateral sclerosis from a
cave in Siberia researchers recovered
DNA contained in a bone fragment of a
woman who lived more than 50,000 years
ago
analysis indicated her mother was a
Neanderthal and her father was a
Denisovan a mysterious group of archaic
humans the finding is the most direct
evidence yet that genetically distinct
types of ancient humans interbred
police detectives have used a new tool
forensic genealogy to crack about 20
cold cases including crimes committed by
the suspected Golden State killer the
criminals
left DNA at the crime scenes the
detectives searched through a public DNA
database to identify people who had
similar DNA and were likely to be
related to the criminals researchers
have developed a technique based on
electron microscopy that allows them to
determine a precise shape of small
organic molecules the new approach is
simple fast and works on tiny samples it
is likely to help speed up drug
discovery and now for the breakthrough
of the year from at least the time of
Hippocrates biologists have been
transfixed by a mystery how does a
single cell develop into an adult animal
with multiple organs and billions of
cells now a combination of technologies
is allowing scientists to track the
development of organisms and organs in
stunning detail cell by cell through
time they can see when genes and
individual cells switch on hewing the
cells to play their specialized parts
the techniques are like having the sheet
music used by an orchestra it indicates
when the strings the brass percussion
woodwinds should chime in to create a
symphony these groundbreaking studies
have already mapped sulfates and
organisms from zebrafish to mice and
more is sure to come science is
recognizing this combination of
technologies and its potential for
spurring advances and basic research and
medicine as the 2018 breakthrough of the
year
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]